bonjour Hervé Marseille bonjour mon
patron du groupe centriste au Sénat
dites-moi monsieur Marseille même au
Sénat c'est difficile d'avoir un débat
serein sur les retraites on vient
d'entendre les échos sonores de la
matinée oui c'est triste nous pensions
qu'il y avait une singularité
sénatoriale que on pouvait débattre
comme on le fait souvent de façon
sereine au fond échanger des arguments
essayer d'améliorer le texte et puis
surtout voter parce que quand on est
parlementaire notre objectif c'est de
débattre et de voter alors à propos de
ce vote bloqué la gauche parle de coup
de force parlementaire aveu de faiblesse
sabordage du Sénat vous approuvez ce
choix du vote bloqué Hervé Marseille oui
parce que la gauche pousse des cris
d'orfray voilà des jours depuis le 2
mars depuis le 2 mars avec 33% de temps
supplémentaires qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale pour débattre la gauche qui
est devenue la nupesse à l'Assemblée ici
au Sénat et bien ses vertus a bloqué le
fonctionnement du Sénat comme d'ailleurs
leurs collègues à l'Assemblée nationale
ont bloqué le fonctionnement de
l'Assemblée pour que nous n'aboutissions
pas et puis pour fragiliser le texte et
l'envoyer devant le Conseil
constitutionnel tout simplement est-ce
que ça veut dire que la réforme sera
adoptée au Sénat plus vite que prévu
théoriquement vous avez jusqu'à dimanche
soir minuit pour examiner le texte ça
ira plus vite que ça écoutez il y a
encore du temps on va pouvoir travailler
plus sereinement et en tous les cas on
va pouvoir aboutir c'est l'objet
d'ailleurs c'est presque surprenant
maintenant qu'on s'étonne qu'une
assemblée finalement des libère sur un
texte c'est formidable mais c'est triste
parce que pour l'avenir c'est inquiétant
pour notre démocratie alors délibère en
accélérant les choses en écartant une
partie des amendements il y a pas un
problème tout de même de légitimité de
cette réforme au bout d'un moment les
les deux tiers de l'opinion opposée à la
réforme l'assemblée qui n'est pas allé
au bout de l'examen qui n'a même pas pu
voter le Sénat qui accélère les choses
en fin de parcours il y a pas un déficit
de légitimité de cette réforme au bout
d'un moment écoutez on est dans un pays
de droit il y a une Constitution il y a
des institutions si on considère que
c'est à la rue au Conseil
constitutionnel de décider des choix
politiques je vous le dis c'est
préoccupant pour l'avenir le rôle des
parlementaires c'est de discuter on
n'est pas obligé d'avoir la même opinion
mais ces deux débattre d'échanger des
arguments et puis de voter c'est la
responsabilité que nous avons
l'assemblée ne l'a pas fait et la gauche
voulait que le Sénat ne le fasse pas non
plus est-ce que c'est la seule
responsabilité de la gauche
bah écoutez si vous regardez les débats
vous verrez que on a dû affronter des
milliers d'amendements tous plus
surprenants que les uns que les autres
ont changé une virgule un point une date
et il en reste encore 1000 il en reste
encore 1000 donc là malgré tout on va
quand même continuer à présenter les
articles les amendements et puis la
différence c'est qu'il y aura un vote à
la fin la gauche d'ailleurs a utilisé
ces possibilités ça vient d'être appelé
pour la réforme Touraine et à
différentes reprises ici au Sénat c'est
constitutionnel merci Hervé Marseille
patron du groupe centriste au Sénat
d'avoir répondu à nos questions